it turns out that Vanguard is pulling
out of ESG did you guys see it's what's
a third of the global capital is that
really yeah pull this up dude this is
like a two-week-old article that's 50
trillion dollars they're not playing
this game they're going economic well
you pull it up there's one like I wanna
like you had mentioned someone to
mentioned talking about like why kids
are depressed like human beings are
human beings this is Vanguard CEO holes
out of the Net Zero managers initiative
and affirms his fiduciary duty to
clients we should this is day one
it's like a week and a half ago yeah
seriously this is them being like hey uh
get what go broke we lost too much money
and uh now we have no choice yes she's
done this is this is it this is it the
blood has been sucked out of the body
it's not done I mean it's it's it's this
is good but the ESG is is pushed by
ideologically motivated people so that's
like saying that a religion is done okay
it's not done but this is an example
that this of capitalism not functioning
with Communism communism is not
profitable and the capitalist system
won't use it well I mean it's it's good
that people are recognizing that ESG is
not good for for for results for
companies and stuff like that and it is
it is communism and it's it's not
particularly it's not intended or or
simply melded with capitalism but if you
look at China
then that's there's another that refute
your argument there because China has a
at least the surface level communist
society and they have markets and that's
what China did China took you know China
took uh the the basics of Marxism now
and you know maoism is is Marxist
leninism with Chinese characteristics
and all they've done is managed to
implement markets but they still have
the control and they still use the
ideology of Communism to to control the
opinions of the population because
America we kind of get this General
sense that everyone in China is feels
like they're oppressed and stuff and I
don't think that that's the case I don't
think a billion and a half people all
hate their government and are just
waiting for the second to rise up it's
way more complex than that so
good yeah I don't know how profitable
Chinese companies are realistically like
real profit like profit doesn't matter
in modern monetary Theory bro they they
are they are printing money and the
system has become so big the Petro
dollars become so big they know that
it's almost impossible to shake the
confidence in the value of the dollar so
they can just Mass print the money and
spend it wherever they want without a
thought no no they I mean not really
Thomas Massey actually was just talking
about this the last five trillion that
was printed was actually just created
out of thin air normally it's right they
always do that no normally they loan it
out you get Thomas Massey's brilliant
man
um and he pointed out that we actually
just diluted our economy I thought it
was always just printed out of thin air
but apparently it's been on the books
and then we're allowed to get it loan to
us so we know ahead of time how much is
going to be there the money the money
supply has expanded when a bank issues a
loan and now this last time they just it
is created it is created it is not when
a bank is issuing a loan the money is
fabricated in that moment yeah they then
just put in your account the loan the
money exists congratulations so I would
push back that I think modern monetary
theory is profitable and that's why it
worked and that what they're doing now
isn't modern monetary Theory you're
supposed to take out a huge loan
invested in infrastructure that you make
more than what you took out and you pay
back the loan that's modern monetary
Theory I don't think that that's
accurate well that's the idea is that's
what they did after World War II that's
not modern monetary Theory modern
monetary theory is is based on the idea
that because
the the issuing country requires that
the people of the country pay taxes in
the the currency that was issued that
means that the currency is always going
to have value because you have to pay
taxes with that currency are you sure
there's no uh like premise of building
infrastructure with the loan building
that's policy that's not monetary policy
that's that's infrastructure policy
different things they have created
demand for the currency by force if you
do not pay what you owe we will lock you
up therefore people are always going I
need dollars and as long as someone
needs the dollars the economy will keep
on churning but this also means it's a
component of it taxes aren't being paid
uh so that we can go to war like Ukraine
the war in Ukraine is not tax dollars
they fabricate this money and it
extracts the buying power from your bank
account so you're you're you're 500
bucks and your bank doesn't move at all
didn't change but what you can buy with
500 bucks does yeah and if you sit if
today I was talking about this a year
ago with the with the covid uh uh
stimulus and all that stuff I put a
tablet in my Amazon cart and then forgot
to buy it and then like a day later
opened up Amazon and it said alert
prices have changed and it went up like
130 bucks and I was like whoa if I
bought that like a week ago I would have
saved a lot of money almost every time I
ordered something on Amazon that I've
ordered in the past I'll check my old
order invoice to look at the old price
versus what I'm about to pay because I'm
fascinated with the changes in price
I'll see like a 10 change here and there
I mean inflation's a real thing that
like that's what Tim's talking about but
that when it comes to like Taxation and
stuff the the tax ju to control
inflation so like when you say you know
you when people talk about paying taxes
to pay bills they don't pay taxes to you
don't pay taxes to pay bills the whole
point of you paying taxes is so that way
there is less currency moving through
the system it's literally taking money
from you specifically so you have less
money is that why taxes started up or
was that if they wanted to do that the
FED could just increase their rates no
no that's not that's the FED increases
the interest rates that's that's the
cost of borrowing money the taxation is
what you is what you have to pay to the
federal government to control inflation
yeah and that's like Tim said it
controls inflation organizations they
suck up the money and they think
government uses taxes as a tool to
control inflation I don't just think yes
I understand that's a fact actually
that's how that is that is literally
that's modern monetary that is modern
monitors I mean they're supposed to so
it's late but they might be using it I
don't know the US government can create
money if they want to quantitative
easing through the fed or Barack Obama
issue that stimulus or as Ian pointed
out the last five trillion was just
fabricated the purpose of paying taxes
is not so that money can be used for war
technically you can say it is but it's
to control for inflation because the
government can manifest money wherever
they want but if they do too much you'll
get runaway inflation so they need to
then bring down the money supply inverse
but like on the state and local level
they're collecting of course to help pay
for that's because they're not property
taxes the federal federal taxes okay
yeah because State and State and local
state and localities don't issue the
currency yeah I just thought that the
most effective tool to control inflation
though would be feds changing the rates
and influencing the money if they
combine it if the U.S government is
through various means or the economy is
expanding the money supply
and there's no controls for that you can
run away inflation you look at these
countries where they just Mass print
money they get trillion dollar bills and
then also it's worthless overnight
because it's hyperinflation so you need
a way to restrict the money supply to
make sure things don't get out of
control so the system doesn't break
you'll find there's the autonomous
massive video I'm referencing is where
he pours water into the iced tea to
explain dilution of the economy and
everyone's like I mean I don't know what
they're doing but he's like explaining
to like third graders it's really
awesome so if you type Thomas Massey
iced tea you might find it on the
internet so like with Nordic countries
they have super high tax rates that's
um they are trying to control and okay
they they can't issue Petro dollars so
for some of these countries it probably
is true but the U.S is the global
Reserve currency so we can just
fabricate money we don't need to and
manufacture apparently according to
Massey uh all the countries of Earth as
well inflated the crap out of their
economy when we printed that five
trillion and that's the only reason or
the main reason why we haven't gone
under yes because everyone's we print
out a ton of money but China prints out
even more and it's interesting how their
economy works but Chrissy do you have
any thoughts on all this money talk I am
learning so much right now can I just
say that I'm like this is over my head
in terms of like my everyday thing and
I'm fascinated because I'm just learning
so much don't you love being the
stupidest person in the room oh hell
yeah it's the best
well you know we're all really dumb and
just talking about our assets I don't
know it feels right I'm gonna have to
fact check everything later yeah I
thought it was about the money supply
and the FED but hey I'm willing to be
real I've never had it I've never had a
thought of my own I only repeat things
that I've heard so I'm not smart wait a
minute but I only learned this from you
philosophy
you can actually Google modern monetary
Theory and oh you can Bing it if you
feel dirty hey because they might have
changed the definition though I thought
that it was about investing in
infrastructure but are you that that's
policy modern monetary theory is the is
the the
the policy that the government has
regarding the monetary uh the monetary
policy the policy you're talking about
is like infrastructure policy so like
they would they would take loans or or
create money so that way they could pay
people that are going to build buildings
or whatever like the new deal yeah
that's that's that's stimulating the
economy that's different than creating
the money that goes into the economy you
know what I mean like the monetary
policy that they have is is different
than like an infrastructure policy
they're different things wasn't there
like a trillion dollars missing from
like the pentagon's books or something
it happens a lot apparently yeah my
conspiracy on that is that we're making
a special little something okay that
that's too much money to just go missing
September 10th but right before 9 11 but
it might not be like one chunk of two
two trillion it might just be accounting
errors yeah
accounting errors can be scary I'll tell
you that because if somebody cross you
know carries a one in the wrong place
then all sudden your tax preparer comes
to you and says you know oh you actually
owe seven thousand more dollars and
you're like how is that possible like
I'm overpaid and they go oh I carried
one in the wrong spot it looked like you
had more money than you did and I'm like
thank you that's you know that's that's
crazy so when it comes to the auditing
problems with the Pentagon and the
Federal Reserve we need to audit them
here it is Donald Rumsfeld in 2001
announced that the Pentagon had lost the
Department of Defense had lost more than
2.3 trillion dollars lost lost but hold
on hold on what's your Source what's
your Source this is a video from how
money works
I mean I've heard this story for two
decades yeah the story I heard was they
could not account for 2.3
but that that means the money is just
not tracked properly it could still be
in their Bank it could have been spent
somewhere but someone you know gave a
hundred thousand dollars from to one
department and then didn't write it down
and so they're like where did that money
go I don't remember but it's still there
yes from Armstrong economics says the
office of the inspector generals
reported that department offense is
missing 6.5 trillion up from 2.3
trillion this is due to an increase in
government spending under the Obama
Administration from 2.9 to 3.5 well all
right that's uh insane so they're
missing 6.5 trillion
I mean that's that's absolutely
scandalous that the government has gone
Rogue I don't know what to do uh Thomas
Jefferson's It's So Scandalous no one
even cares thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time